it is clearly now the will of the
Parliamentary conservative party that
there should be a new leader of that
party and therefore a new prime minister
countless political scandals and 59
ministerial resignations later Boris
Johnson has now resigned but just
because he's resigned doesn't mean he's
going anytime soon
Johnson seems determined to remain as
caretaker prime minister until his
replacement is elected by the Tory party
however former conservative prime
minister John Major as well as many Tory
MPS and opposition parties are all
calling on him to go now
before his resignation Boris Johnson
hired new members of his cabinet
replacing everyone who had quit and I've
today appointed a cabinet to serve but
the government is essentially in a
limbo-like state where everyone's on a
temporary contract
the darwinian system will
be equally committed to taking this
country forward through tough times I've
agreed with sir Graham Brady the
chairman of our back bench MPS the
process of choosing that new leader
should begin now and the timetable will
be announced next week if the Tory party
acts quickly they could have their top
two nominees for the next leader before
the end of July before summer
parliamentary recess and that could mean
they could have a new leader by
September but the real power here lies
with the 1922 committee the committee of
Tory MP back benches and they decide the
timings when it comes to nominations and
elections and therefore it's up to them
when Boris Johnson goes